all right people we are live on the
YouTube and the Facebook and I am with a
best-selling author a radio host and a
man who once beat me senseless in front
of millions of people larry elder
welcome back to the reuben report round
two well this will be around three how
are you this is so we're at Taraki
through c but if it was rocky no no it's
like Muhammad Ali and Frazier right Ali
lost the first one Frazier I leave lost
the first one one the second one and
then they had to had the big third one
thrilla in manilla this is thriller in
Manila since thriller I wish this was
more like Rocky because in the original
Rocky they it was to a standstill Rocky
one right nobody wins
rocky two rocky finally wins and then
three well at that point you're I think
Ruben the only question is which one of
us is ollie which one was Frazier all
right so you just sat down here but
we've already talked about comic books
about basketball
only black panther yeah about racism
about Trump I think we covered
everything by look all right well let's
do a little bit of in for the people so
I first I just want to jump back to that
original moment because I said it to you
last time you were here which was about
a year ago and when that that moment
where you really beat me senseless about
systemic racism that was about two years
ago already if not more at this point
and so many people I was just in London
two days ago and I did a Q&A and people
were asking me about it I mean that
thing really has there are many versions
of it on YouTube it's just caught fire
and as I said to you last time it was
sort of I view it as my best moment as
and my worst it was my worst because I
came to an intellectual fight without
the proper equipment and it was my best
because we left it in and let it be and
it was a learning moment for me and then
for everyone else well you had a lot of
class for leaving it and a lot of people
would have would have taken it out and
no one would have known it happened and
secondly the older one gets the more
difficult it is for one to kind of
change one's beliefs and for you to do
it at your age to rethink your
assumptions I takes a lot of a lot of
guts a lot of people don't want to do
that and I'd be a pretty depressing
thing don't you think well I agree with
you most people don't want to do it I
think we've fostered here's something
that is allowing people to do it
but most people don't want to do that
you know and it's funny we're in an
atmosphere where just a moment ago I'm
driving in listening to a talk radio and
they could CNN or MSNBC and they're
going on and on about how Trump has now
made lying the currency of the day and
and no one tells the truth any more
facts don't matter and they're talking
about the kinds of lying that Trump does
where he talks about the crowd size and
how much money he has and stuff like
that
the lies of the left are huge lies and
they damage the country the lie that
racism remains a major problem in
America it's a lie the lie that women
make 77 cents on the dollar for doing
the same thing that men do it it's a lie
the lie that rich get rich the poor get
poorer these are lies and these are big
lies that drive the left and drive votes
these are the kinds of things that
matter so when you sit across from a guy
like me and the first time we did it
when I really still felt I was part of
the left I was trying to reform the left
realistically I'm not part of the left
anymore it you know and again the
left/right thing is we talk about all
the time doesn't even have that much
meaning anymore it's really about
authoritarians libertarians and all that
but for all the years that you've been
doing this staking out conservative
positions for how many years publicly a
25 25 years was there a more sensible
left at the time was there a guy you
could sit across from that you disagreed
with intellectually but felt that it was
it was forthright it was honest you just
disagreed with the methodology and the
result sure there were lots of people
that I felt that way with and William F
Buckley had a very good friend John
killin Kenneth Galbraith who was a
left-wing economist they disagreed about
everything there were good friends
believe it or not Antonin Scalia's best
friend on the Supreme Court's Ruth Bader
Ginsburg what it requires is somebody to
recognize that if I have a position
that's different from yours it doesn't
mean that I'm a bad guy it doesn't mean
that I'm evil it means if I see the
world differently it takes a certain
kind of maturity to do that
unfortunately the gun to the place now
where if you don't believe that racism
is a major problem in America if you're
a black you're a sellout if you're white
you're a racist if you say something
negative about the Black Panther which I
just did I got hammered some some guy
told me that well it's because it's a
black person and a black director and a
black hero and therefore you don't like
it
I mean the star is guy named Chadwick
Boseman and I was fortunate enough to be
invited to see the premiere of 42 he was
brilliant
I saw the movie three or four times
I like him so much I saw him in a movie
about Thurgood Marshall which was a very
good movie probably not commercially
successful but it was a very good movie
and I saw him play in the movie with uh
we played James Brown he was very good
the movie wasn't that good but he was
good yeah so he's an intriguing actor
again I don't go to see a movie to not
be happy to waste my time yeah and
you're a comic book guy I mean I said
about comic books is cuz I've got a
whole bunch in the green room here and
you were immediately going on about all
this stuff you love so it's not like
you're walking into that thing to hate
it right and so the criticism is just
bizarre I mean what do you think I am
what do you think I do I get up in the
morning hate myself
gouge my eyeballs out try to claw my
skin color off me that's just and and
and and Dave I feel sorry for people
like that people have often asked me
does it make you mad it doesn't I feel
sorry for you if you are so trained so
indoctrinated to be let's rabbit against
somebody who just has a different point
of view there's a problem with you not
with me you know well on that note I owe
you a public thanks not just because you
beat me senseless and help me get here
but also because everyone knows about
the interview I did with Thomas Sol and
we had been working on for about three
years you sent him a note I don't know
if that was what pushed him over the
edge but I think it was one of the
really one of the big things that I've
been able to do here to bring some of
those ideas back and that's what you've
been doing for a long time he's like
he's like JD Salinger it's hard it's
hard it's hard it's hard to get him we
have to get him out once you get him
he's amazing yeah and I met him because
I was on c-span at the time I had a four
hour live radio show and c-span
broadcasted the entire show and I get a
letter from Thomas Saul it was like
getting a letter from Elvis and it said
my wife and I watch your entire show you
were great you you you laid out all the
arguments very well done and I wrote him
back and we got together several times
since then we become very good friends
yeah so I sense a massive shift
happening in politics right now and
clearly the center of it right at the
moment is with the black community I
don't even like using phrases like that
because I don't like that collective
thing but sometimes you gotta you got to
talk about things in a way that allow
most people to understand them so you
know what is it about two-and-a-half
weeks ago or so Kanye West seven words I
love the way Candace Owens thinks Wow
yeah now do you think that it is as big
a seismic shift
yeah I think it is a game-changer yeah
in the sense that Kanye West has 28
million Twitter followers I don't know
how many Instagram I know how many
Facebook would you add them all together
it's a boatload of people yeah he has
more influence on the way black people
think then Clarence Thomas Thomas Sol
Walter Williams Larry older put together
unfortunately and for him to to say that
and to begin the process of making it
okay for black people to rethink their
assumption they can okay to say I'm not
a Democrat that's a huge thing
ninety-five percent of black voters
voted for Obama Trump did a little bit
better but not a whole lot better if the
Democrats lose 10 15 20 percent of that
black vote
they are toast at the national level
which is why people like me have to be
vilified people like Candace Owens are
now direct threats to the domination of
the Democratic Party people like Kanye
West they've got to be put down they've
got to be demeaned you can't just say
he's got a different point of view
you've got to say something that's
fundamentally fundamentally wrong with
them otherwise how would you get 95% of
people to vote and see the world one way
we have to show them prove to them
convince them that they these guys are
against you that that you're a victory
at and these are victimizers and that's
what the left has done so successfully
and so when you saw the reaction to him
now again I briefly discussed this but I
don't think either one of us know what
his political beliefs are even if he has
he knows what they are but just just not
to hate Republicans not to hate Trump
for that is a big deal
think you know we're in Hollywood you
and I are is there an a-list our doing
it here I have no is there an a-list
actor and a-list actress in his or her
20s or 30s who come out and said I love
Trump none nobody you get some older
ones maybe they've already established
you've set a few things but is there
somebody right now who's hot on the
brink of stardom or just just in stardom
who's come out in favor of Trump know
you'll get a Trump just say basic
conservatives yeah because they'll be
damaging to their career it's not
possible that 100% of them think the
same way I don't think so
there's got to be a few but when they
come out and say something of course not
how'd you get a walk a fame star I'm
sure would you pay up for that bag well
when someone asked me that reporter said
how did that happen I said well this is
what happens when you make a substantial
donation to the Clinton Foundation I
have no idea I know that I'm nominated
all the time because I would get some
sort of inquiry from people telling me
that you've been nominated and nothing
ever happened so I didn't think anything
would happen lo and behold who knows
yeah when you think of the odd levels of
racism in this town like just the way
they do things like just a couple weeks
ago when they boot Cosby out of the
whatever it is the television weekend or
it's a long long ad so then they do
Roman Polanski the same day but it was
so obvious that it was like oh we got to
take care of Cosby now but we don't want
to make it seem like we're just booting
the black guy so where's the white guy
we can get rid of and you know I don't
think anything to do with black or white
I think they realize the hypocrisy I
think they realize if we're kicking out
Bill Cosby because of allegations of
rape yeah and here's a guy who pled
guilty to rape a teenager yeah and we're
celebrating him we have a problem here
so cause we caused them to have to be
consistent they do with with Polanski's
race or Carly's race he had to do with
with the with the bizarre concept of
somebody being booted out because he was
accused of rape and somebody who was
charged with it and pled guilty to it
he's okay I think in their own warped
worldview though if Cosby had been white
and they felt they had to get rid of him
they wouldn't have felt that they needed
to get rid of another white guy maybe I
get it is believe me it's possible but
they've caused us to think this way
right I'm just trying to get in their
minds I'm not trying to get in right in
our minds but okay I want to get back to
what you just said about the reaction to
Kanye because the reaction to me it
seemed it wasn't just people were like
he's wrong because he likes Trump
because you know lists for things that
are sensible it was you know Candace is
far right Kanye's on opioids ten other
smear pieces on both of them etc etc and
I think you're probably very aware of
why that is and you kind of hinted at it
but can you explain why it's always so
overboard
well again anybody who threatens the 95
percent monolithic black vote is an
enemy they've got to be dealt with
they've got to be put down
and black people have been indoctrinated
to believe that racism is this massive
massive problem in the world when in
fact it isn't massive massive problem in
America when in fact it isn't yeah I was
on CNN the last time I was on this Don
Lemon show I reminded them of a 1997
poll that seeing him and Time magazine
did where black teenagers and white
teenagers were asked is is racism major
problem in America I think you and I
might have talked about this and more
more white teams and black teams that
racing there was a major problem in
America and then when the poll asked is
racism a big problem a small problem or
no problem in your own daily lives
ninety percent of the black teen said a
small problem no probably in my own
daily lives that was in 1997
now that was before Obama and a for
Obama got reelected you're telling me
now things are worse now than they were
back then yet our so-called black
leadership people like keith Ellison
people like Louis Farrakhan people like
Jesse Jackson people like Sharpton the
the the the the neighbor observing on
MSNBC ha and CNN if you contracted on
those guys you'd be afraid to leave your
house if you were black so what do you
think is actually going on in the minds
of these guys I know you're not a mind
reader but like is it is it truly bad
intentions or is it moral confusion
political party it's hard it's hard to
say I think some of it is cynical some
of it is is BS recently for example I
just saw that a chapter head of an in in
a a CP chapter in South Carolina wrote a
big Facebook post about being pulled
over and the officer s about drugs and
asking him about why are you having such
a fancy car and he wrote a big piece
Facebook post about it unfortunately the
the officer recorded everything and it
turned out everything the guy said was a
lie this is the chapter head of the
n-double a-c-p in that town in South
Carolina now if racism so bad that you
have to make up stuff man that shows you
the the the call that victimhood has
right now for whatever remember the
young lady the actors from the movie
Django here in on Santa Monica and she
was apparently having sex with her
boyfriend in her car somebody called 911
recorded
she was wrong and a judge made her write
a letter of apology I mean really so
what do you do what do you do I was at
University of New Hampshire two weeks
ago and there were a bunch of protesters
there black lives matter sent a bunch of
people and I kept saying that I'm for
everyone having you know equal respect
under the law and I think you can't say
that's racist I even said black lives
matter because I was I did everything I
could to make it clear that I want us
all to be treated equally with dignity
with I mean you but you know what it's
like when you get some of these
protesters the ones that are not not a
not an average protester who may want to
listen a little bit and then and then
ask a question right when you get the
ones that are just there to to berate
and scream and the rest so one of the
one of the protesters are there a couple
at one point who were saying you know
something like we could be shot when we
get out of here all this hate speech all
of the stuff and I realized even though
I kept saying what I believe to be true
and what I believed to be right there
was almost nothing I can do
right so what do you do for those people
because I think the masses are shifting
a little bit but what do you do for that
you you're not gonna win every argument
you really can't and if somebody is
invested with the idea that the man is
holding me back that officers pull me
over because of my race there's not a
whole lot you can do about it you can
point to studies I mean it's been
studied under Obama in the 20 2013 I
think it was the National Institutes of
justice which is the research arm of the
DOJ did a study what called race and
traffic stops turned out 75 percent of
the black motorists who were stopped
said I got stopped for legitimate
reasons it turned out that you named a
traffic offense speeding driving without
your lights on driving without a seat
belt on driving without proper
registration you name the offense a
black motorist was what was more likely
to commit it and the NIJ report said yes
blacks are stopped more often than
whites are but the reasons have to do
with quote differences in offending end
of quote came out under Obama quietly
nobody talked about it how much of this
then is just a failure of what the
Republicans have done I get you on all
of the things that the Democrats and the
left had sold that are lies I get the
way they they manipulate all these
different minority communities but it
seems to me because there is a
resurgence now right like the first
thing I said to time is soul are you are
you excited that you know
you're having this resurgence he kind of
looked at me like well you know doing
this for 50 years
sort of or that that people now share
the clip of us endlessly and Candice and
Connie and all of this it this does seem
to be coming back but some of this has
to be on the Republicans too right that
it got so bad well yeah I mean the
Republic have done a bad job in in
marketing their brand most people don't
even know that the Democrats opposed at
thirteen fourteen fifteen amendment
sometimes unanimously most people don't
know that as a percentage of the party
more Republican voted for the passage of
the Civil Rights Act in the Senate and
in the house then did Democrats and
there's this myth that what happened is
it was a big switch in the 60s when all
the racists from the South left the
Democratic Party and joined a publican
party when in fact if you look at all of
the Democrats that voted against the
Civil Rights Act in the house and the
Democrats of all of them only to switch
parties became Republicans the first
Republican senator from Tennessee since
reconstruction was a guy named Howard
Baker who was a guy who's in favor of
integration so it's it's a big lie and
Republicans have done a poor job in and
telling the truth the other thing is
Republicans are gentle when they're
called racists they often just don't say
anything or ignore it I hope the moment
goes away recently Mike Kelly from
Pennsylvania a Republican member of the
House squared off with Maxine Waters it
was this bogus report that purported to
show that auto dealers jack over black
people by charging a more interest rates
to get loans when in fact all these
things are done by algorithms there's
nothing to do with race at all and Mike
Kelly happened to be in the car business
well he knew it wasn't true and he
challenged her and he said something to
the effect of we Republicans have an
obligation to when we are confronted
with nonsense to call it and we need it
we need to start calling it and that's
the problem
people often say to me Larry you can say
stuff we can't say yeah really you you
are incapable of particularly in the
words I just your brain cannot put out
the conversation I just did yeah and
that's the problem when white people
have called racist why don't you defend
yourself you know who you are you know
how you feel you know what you've done
you know what your thoughts are and
someone calls you races and you let it
go
I mean it's a problem yeah are you
feeling this glow right now I mean you
must be feeling pretty good about this
like something has shifted here it's got
a it's got to feel good right I can I
can sense that well you saw a poll and
it showed I'm big on facts not unfeeling
facts I was letting you have a feeling
thank you the the polls showed that the
support for Trump doubled among black
men incredible right I'm 11 to 22 years
yeah and in less than a week in about a
week and it shows you there was a dyke
and once the Dyke broke it broke and the
support for blacks in general has
increased about 50% for Trump over the
last few weeks all it because Kanye
West's Candace Owen have made it okay
for people all around the country to
have conversations like you and I are
having right now yeah and these kind of
conversations are taking place and
blackly we're saying wait a second
Donald Trump wants to build a wall and
do something about illegal immigration
in part because studies have shown
there's a economist named George Borja
he probably done more work on the impact
of illegal immigration any other
economists there's no question he writes
that illegal immigration unskilled
especially poses competition for jobs
for people in the inner city and puts
downward pressure on their wages so
Donald Trump one still wants to do
something about that and studies have
shown that when parents have vouchers
the results are better the kids graduate
at a higher rate their test scores are
better and the parental satisfaction is
through the roof and Donald Trump wants
to provide inner-city parents with the
vouchers and the polls show that the
nursing parents want them and the
teachers union which is right in the
pocket of the Democratic Party and vice
versa
does not want you to have those but
Donald Trump is a bigot so people all
around the country having this
conversation and the economy has done
well and under Obama the black labor
force participation rate the percentage
of black men looking for jobs or working
hadn't been that low since they were
keeping stats and under Donald Trump
black unemployment isn't at all-time low
in part because these lower taxes and
stop turning back some of these stupid
regulations that strangle businesses and
when business doesn't do well the people
that suffer the most are the people at
the bottom the ones that need a job and
don't have a job and Donald Trump is
doing something about that but he's a
racist well that's kind of a dip
argument to make his daughter is a
converted Jew yeah one member of his
cabinet is the formally respected Ben
Carson but Donald Trump's are bigoted
don't forget our openly gay now
ambassador to Germany Rick Grinnell
right and the series and don't forget
all the halyard and all you see if
Donald Trump hanging out with Jesse
Jackson and Al Sharpton back in the day
when when they thought that that he
could benefit them now all of a sudden
he's a bigot it's outrageous and that
conversations being taking place all
over the country also rappers as you
well know used to rap about Trump all
the time ya know once I have a word he's
were weren't his name Ryan to a lot of
stuff so they used it and they often
talked about aspiring to be like charm
then he ran for president he became an
sob how did that happen do you think he
was just the guy that was the only guy
that could have done it basically I
think so
Hillary was the best funded best bat
candidate I've ever seen and it took
somebody to take on the media and to cut
through CNN and MSNBC through social
media also Trump snuck up on people the
media is really angry at themselves for
that it can happen I read that he got
about two billion dollars in free
advertising now laugh that was bad yeah
but but the numbers went up whenever
they said whenever they show them the
numbers went up and and theirs began
knocking off people and knocking off
people they realized that he was being
taken seriously and then it was too late
yeah you know it's interesting you
mentioned that that poll that 11 to 22
percent amongst black male poll that
thing came out I quickly saw it on
Twitter and then I kind of looked around
I was like wait a minute
this seems massive like why we shouldn't
understate this a doubling of support
right now if at any point it had doubled
under Obama although as you're saying it
was high enough to the point that he
probably couldn't have doubled but under
it right any other situation if any
other minority the media would even go
on bananas and it wasn't I think as I
recall a respected poll - wasn't it
Reuters I'm not totally sure but by
every estimation is a legit legit poll
yeah yeah so that just shows you where
the media is at with this they can't
talk about it to talk about it also then
Lynn's
energy to it and would encourage more
and more people to rethink their
assumption so let's just ignore it yeah
I once asked Thomas Sol when you write a
column like this I forget would call me
would throw some column and then
challenging the assumption of race-based
preferences
and he challenged some big study and I
said when when you write something like
this and you effectively refute some
study what happens
he said usually nothing
he said they bore it the guy and they
move on to something else yeah man it's
a long game here it's a long long game
for sure so when I've had you on one of
the push backs that I get after people
always say well all right
oh I'll grant him a little something
like if they're willing to give you a
little something they'll go all right he
may be right we don't have laws that are
against black people so it's not
systemic if that's what you're defining
systemic as and people seem to have a
couple different definitions of systemic
but they'll they'll talk about the
history of inequality and why that needs
to be compensated for now now I suspect
you might say well most of those
policies that have created that
inequality or because of the Democrats
but that's the last word I'm going to
put in your mouth well how do you
acknowledge that argument well all a
state can be it's just in its own time
my father wasn't a slave my father never
met his father but I'm sure he wasn't a
slave either and so the people right now
on the face of the earth have had
nothing to do with historical injustice
is to black people and you could take a
wand and wave it over America and remove
every smidgen of racism from the hearts
of white America how will that solve the
social problems that are really facing
the black community primarily the large
number of black kids they're raised with
our fathers in the home 73 percent right
now 73 percent right now black kids are
raised with our fathers 25 percent of
inner-city black kids have a criminal
record either arrested in jail on parole
or on probation fifty percent of the
inner-city kids are dropping out of high
school and those that do graduate often
cannot read write a computer grade level
what does any of that have to do with
racism in many of these cities and
school boards have been run by Democrats
and run by black people for decades so
okay so if we remove the racism part of
it but acknowledge those numbers your
answer would be that we have to what
then change the education system I mean
for me it's the you got to start it off
at all starts what stall starts in the
home yeah recently I was pleased to
watch Denzel Washington being
interviewed about his movie Roman Jay
Israel yeah
which was about a criminal defense
lawyer and someone put a mic in this in
his face and asked Denzel Washington
what about the large number of blacks
who were being warehoused by the
criminal justice system and I just knew
he was going to say something about yeah
we need to do something about the system
that grazes and blah blah blah he didn't
he said it all starts in the home I saw
it in my generation in every generation
thereafter if you're raised by the
streets then the streets become your
father and the course become your home
and the jail becomes your residence
that's what he said something to that
effect yeah and it was spot on I didn't
expect it and again I think things like
that when you add them all up will cause
people to start rethinking their
assumptions yeah are you feeling it like
when you're doing your radio show and
you're taking calls now are you it's are
it's hard to say because you know this
is a I'm often preaching to the crowd I
like to think that the reason my numbers
are so big is that I'm getting people
that don't normally listen to a
conservative / libertarian talk-show
host but it's hard to say because the
people call-in or motivated they're
driven to call them they don't
necessarily represent the the entire
population base so it's hard to say Plus
you choose calls because they're
entertaining because the person has a
good point of view has a good speaking
voice gets to the point quickly so there
are all sorts of factors that go into it
so it's not scientific yeah I like the
you just described yourself as a
conservative / libertarian because I
think on the libertarian side of stuff I
think we're pretty much you know as
close to lockstep as you can get what do
you think see is the differences between
those two positions does it even matter
to you well the reason I use that is
because people often call me a
conservative I don't consider myself
that I consider myself to be a
libertarian a smaller libertarian who's
a registered Republican I don't run from
the term conservative and most of my
views are conservative but I but I'm
more libertarian than know what is
conservative even mean to you anymore
what is like the phrase if you're legal
when I think of a contribute think of a
fiscal conservative and a social
conservative and on things like same-sex
marriage things like doctor sister
suicide things like like drugs
I believe all those things should be
done on a state-by-state basis I'm a
federalist that way yeah a lot of
conservatives are perfectly okay with in
my opinion passing laws that would ban
certain behavior that they don't like
and and I'm I'm not I
in that camp I guess also conservatives
probably I remember listening to Ann
Coulter Ann Coulter was talking about
how she opposed the the idea of
legalizing drugs and talked about the
cost to society for that
well a libertarian wouldn't think that
way at all that you just accept that
what price to pay for freedom base could
be freedom is expensive it's a value in
and of itself yeah and when you talk
about the cost of this the cost of that
what about the cost of freedom what
about the value of freedom value the
value of being able to do what you want
provided you're not hurting somebody
else so when you said something to the
effect of that we're all men of our own
time do you think all you can be it's
just in here oh you can be as just in
your honor that's even better so when
you said that if we were to look back
when we had federal laws and that were
that actually were racist and Jim Crow
laws and things like that and then we
had the Civil Rights Act of 1963 or 64 I
always forget 64 now that stopped it at
the federal level would you have been
okay
if the states had dealt with that
because I get that one a lot now because
people will say maybe you're a
libertarian they made the argument it's
probably the biggest question and the
biggest argument that people have
against libertarians yeah Barry
Goldwater loaded against the Civil
Rights Act of 1964 he became the
standard bearer for the Republican Party
in 64 he later on said he regretted his
vote against the bill but at the time he
said I'm voting against the bill because
of libertarian reasons he wasn't a
racist he didn't believe the government
should tell you if you're operating a
store or whether or not somebody could
come in to come out and whether or not
you are should be forced to serve
somebody and he is not wrong I know that
freaks a lot of black people out but
think about it the country changed
rapidly and laws can't make you change
we change and therefore the laws changed
because we changed America changed and
bigotry there's zero tolerance for anti
black white bigotry zero tolerance for
in America
my goodness anyone
outed as a bigot gets hammered look what
happened to Donald sterling he lost his
team for crying out loud so some guy
somewhere decided he wanted to open up a
bar and no black people come in sign
that says only whites he would be
socially maligned friends who go there
of friends who go there would malign the
person when I lived in Cleveland in the
70s there was an area called Little
Italy and I was told if you got a little
italy and you're black they will spit in
your food they don't want you there
everybody everybody I know told me that
so nobody I know went there anybody I
know who did go there if they told
anybody they were socially scorned and
in 14 years I was living in Cleveland
Little Italy got smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller so racism is not
financially beneficial the reason Branch
Rickey hired Jackie Robinson was not to
be a civil rights pioneer he won't to
beat the damn Yankees and he wanted a
fast shortstop or first baseman who
could do it
and once other teams realized that these
guys were good they had to get him to
yeah so although I can tell you wouldn't
be for reversing the Civil Rights Act
you could make an argument in a modern
sense for that all of these things
should just be kicked to the States
right correct yeah I'm there on that too
which I think people always libertarians
and we are in regarding federal
institutions like schools and things
like that that are that are government
of course the Fourteenth Amendment
applies but can you explain why because
again this is where I think people just
get lost
well the Fourteenth Amendment says no
state shall deny anybody equal
protection so it's got to be a state
actor a college or university that state
but a private university should be able
to do what they want even though none of
them can because everybody accepts
federal dollars and therefore the
government can tell you what to do there
is one University Hillsdale and a few
others that don't take any any federal
money and therefore they can admit who
they want by whatever criteria they want
and that ought to be what what should
happen in any institution in the private
sector whether it's a grocery store or
or or college a university what do you
make of just the line of thinking that
we would ever be able to set a series of
laws in place that would perfect the
whole
because that's really what this comes
down to they they think basically we can
just we can basically riddle away your
ability to think really right and then
you'll all act like sort of automatons
and behave and no one will be racist
then whatever but at the same time and
we know this because of Silicon Valley
right now
no one will be able to come up with the
ingenuitive thought no it'll have an
original premise or ability to do
anything cool anymore right well that's
a problem with the left that's why
they're moral busybody so right now and
I think of Seattle they just passed a
law that's going to tax businesses so
that so that they can build more more
shelter for homeless people
the more you encourage this kind of
behavior in Seattle last week a lot of
homeless people are gonna get yeah have
you been downtown LA recently yeah up in
Seattle up in up in San Francisco these
are all places that are all left-wing
and they're very generous and they all
feel sorry for the homeless and
therefore they're making it easier
easier easier for homeless people all
over the country to move there and
making it easier and easier for you to
be a little less responsible because you
know you're gonna get a house there's
somebody else is gonna pay for ya so as
a guy that you were born in LA right so
you were born and raised in LA first off
why am I gone
why did you do a singing first I don't
know where I'm gonna go with that yeah
if you're not you know at you director
by flow so why haven't you run against
Maxine Waters already I mean what are
you doing for God's sake let me support
you please I would lose I I supported a
guy named Ross Moen against her a few
years ago and I this is the only time I
ever really went out and campaign for
somebody else I mean I made speeches for
him don't it gave money to him heading
on my radio show a bunch of times
Vietnam vet great guy white guy and he
lost I want to say 84% to 16% I mean it
was just a smashing she she has that
district in her hands and I mean she
strikes me as actually dangerous to
democracy at a certain level well she
keeps going up we're gonna we're gonna
find the reason to write peach him she
who the president is forget what you
think she is dangerous but but David
tell you who I think it's more dangerous
people like Eric Holder because Eric
Holder is taken seriously by the left
Maxine Waters the caricature they have
her for the reason I mentioned earlier
to keep black people angry to stoke up
the anger but no one
takes us seriously when Eric Holder
comes out and says that the fact that
black boys are Dysport ly expelled from
their schools compared to their
population percentage when he calls that
pernicious racism when in fact is
because of their bad behavior that's
taken seriously when Eric Holder says
that the reason blacks get longer
sentences compared to white criminal
defendant who committed the same crime
when the US Sentencing Commission says
the reason is because judges taken in
consideration arrest records at the end
of the sentencing process and the black
criminal defendant unfortunately has a
big arrest arrest record to the average
white guy who gets arrested for the same
crime and Eric Holder in a speech
referred to that disparity as precious
racism even though the Sentencing
Commission said what I just now said
Eric Holder says that the push for voter
ID which the majority of blacks want is
Prius racism this guy is taken seriously
but that's the one that really bothers
me that when they imply that somehow
black people can't get an ID I mean you
have to have an ID to drive a car right
you have to have an ID to go into a bar
some some of some of the events that
Maxine Waters puts on you have to have
an ID to get into but really that like
did they not realize that that's actual
racism was condescending to is just it's
an in oh yeah do you remember I think we
discussed this once but I'd love to just
dive back into it for a second like a
moment in your formative years your
younger years when you finally were just
like this is what it is and I'm just I'm
just going to say what it is I can't
think of a time like that I I know that
had been many times where I've said
things and gotten gotten hell for it I
remember being in college we read Daniel
Patrick Moynihan's reported the
Commission that to you called a Negro
family National Action a classical
liberal by the way Daniel packed right
and I got hammered by the whites of my
class for being Pro patriarchal I think
over the term that was used and I'm in
the Rays in the inner city and I saw a
problem and I thought that Daniel
Patrick Patrick Moynihan was a was the
canary in the coal mine and talked about
this problem so I said so and I got
hammered I don't remember any particular
moment I've always just been confident
about Who I am and what I
and my parents always told me that I
could be whatever I wanted to be and my
dad was a Republican and so I watched
all my dad walk into a voting booth this
is during the primary season and in my
neighborhood and because there's nothing
but Democrats there there must have been
about 10 or 12 little booth when you
stand in for the Democrat one for
Republicans for that rare guy that came
there and it's my dad he's the only
Republican in my whole neighborhood he
would come up there and everybody of
course see he's a Republican because
he'd walk up there he didn't care
and he knew that a lot of blacks felt
Republicans were bad people and evil
people he didn't care my father couldn't
have cared less and yeah it's just this
this thing around race it's gross I I
hate the fact that I even when we have
you on that we end up talking about it
is gross especially when you when you
consider America is the least racist
white majority Society in the country
the only one has ever elected a black
president and re-elected one Orlando
Patterson the he's a left-wing
sociologist at Harvard said America has
more opportunities for blacks in any
other country in the entire world
including all of those in Africa yeah
best fed best educated you know and here
we are bitching and moaning and whining
about what happened during slavery and
Jim Crow
I mean honestly in order to to be
successful this was a this was a an aide
to Bill Clinton he said you need to do
three things to escape poverty graduate
from high school don't have a kid before
you're 20 and get married before you
have a kid if you follow that formula
only seven or eight percent of people
are poor however if you don't follow
that formula majority of people are
going to be poor that's it now what does
it have to do with racism what does it
do with David Duke explain that to me
yeah let's talk about that part of it
though so the the David dukes it's so
silly to even have to bring him up or
just whatever the whatever the truly
racist part of the right is and I do
believe it does exist there there are
racists there are actual races there are
you know some of this some of the all
right crew whatever that captains in the
Farrakhan on the left absolutely I just
want to give it the devil is due on the
right for a moment however however David
Duke doesn't have a TV show well that's
what every Sunday on MSNBC the way our
Sharpton does al Sharpton falsely
accused the white man of raping Tawana
Brawley
referred to Mayor David Dinkins the
first and only black mayor of New York
has an n-word [ __ ]
he was right in the thick of the Crown
Heights riot which was the most serious
program in the history of the of America
he's on tape urging Jews to pend their
yarmulkes and come over my house let's
get it on
he's on a surveillance tape with the FBI
are discussing doing a cocaine deal
he owes five million dollars in taxes
he's got a TV show on MSNBC every Sunday
interviewing a list important people
Scotty beam me up and so when I hear all
this stuff about the the racism on the
right and this guy has a show
I mean it's outrageous and Don Lemon
recently referred to Brock to the Donald
Trump quote as a racist nothing happened
Glenn Beck who's not a news guy he's a
commentator called Barack Obama racist
and a group called Color of Change which
is a major Sorrells backed left-wing
organization put a petition targeting
his advertisers nobody had a problem
with Don Lemon calling Trump a racist
but calling Obama racist oh my goodness
bring out the pitchforks is the problem
there that you don't want your side in
this case to start using the same
tactics so it's almost it becomes like
an uneven battlefield right so like
what's her name on Fox
Laura Ingraham says the thing about
David hog was it right and then and then
she gets boycotted and Fox definitely at
least for a couple days was considering
firing her um I'm told on pretty good
account I know that yeah and or at least
you know there was going to be some sort
of longer suspension or something and
that the right doesn't do that the right
just did somebody on the left says I'm
crazy or or just let's use the case of
the guy you're talking about so I'll
sharpen he's on MSNBC and it's just like
yeah all right nobody's watching it's
nonsense like well the double standards
we did it's it's just it's in the cake a
recent example of that is this staffer
apparently a low-level staffer in the
White House was discussing the fact that
John McCain apparently is gonna vote
against Gina Hass ball the nominee for
the CIA and this staffer said something
to the effect of that's okay he's dying
anyway close quote how that got out is
beyond me but it gets out her name gets
out and now Donald Trump is being
attacked because he hasn't apologized to
John McCain and John McCain's family for
with this low-level staffer says
when Obama was in office and it was 2014
a quote senior Obama official close
quote was how the hill described it
referred to Benjamin Netanyahu the Prime
Minister of Israel as chicken bleep
except it wasn't bleep yeah and also
called him a coward nobody nobody
pressured Obama and apologizing and
Obama didn't apologize John Kerry did
too - not in Yahoo but but Trump but the
Obama was not pressured into into saying
this now what's worse calling one of our
closest allies chicken bleep or some
low-level staffer referring to a senator
because of his vote and it doesn't
matter he's gonna dying anyway which is
worse and which one caused the more
controversy the one about McCain did the
one about Obama tree fell in the forest
didn't make a sound so with all the
understandable disdain that you have for
the mainstream media and I'm with you on
all of that and and you know the things
that I see people say about you and just
this group of people that I know to be
decent human beings are you at all
concerned that if the mainstream media
completely collapses which I would argue
either has already happened or is an
inevitability at least at this point
that what we're going to be left with is
such a siloing of opinion that we are
going to be completely unable to have
any sort of national conversation look
maybe that gets everything back to a
local level which I would be okay with
but are you concerned with that at all
I'm not I'm not one of those who thinks
things are worse now than they've ever
been and this is a country where we
fought over big issues for a long time
Revolutionary War of course and then of
course we had the war of 1812 we had the
Civil War World War One World War two
Vietnam Korean War we 9/11 people hated
Ronald Reagan they thought he was a war
monger George Bush was a bush live
people died there's tension in this
country there always has been for a very
long period of time
we get along better now than ever before
we've been I don't think you can
understate the fact that we elected
re-elected a black president in the 50s
the polls show that the percentage of
white Americans who will be willing to
vote for a black person no matter how
well a qualified was in the single
digits and now I think only three or
four percent of Republicans and
Democrats say
then under no circumstances would they
vote for a black person for president in
fact there's greater prejudice against
the Mormon and it gets voting for a
woman than it is voting for a black
person now so America is a very
different place than it used to be and
and for the left to act like it's not
insults the men and women who worked
hard to get us to where we are right now
yeah well just that lack of
acknowledgement of how things have moved
forward when I did this University of
New Hampshire thing last week I said at
the beginning of the speech I said
everyone in this room I would say I
would guess this without exception that
everyone in this room has it better than
their grandparents had it and I didn't
see anyone nodding nobody nobody said no
there's they're still yelling at me
after about all of this this stuff
meanwhile they're at an extremely good
school and all of those things but it's
a lack of acknowledgement of reality
right and give you a sort of a trivial
example personal example I was in school
in college in the late 70s and I met a
woman later on in Cleveland I met a
woman whose father was an aeronautical
engineer and he was about 10 years
younger than my dad and I said sure
first if he was an engineer and I said
what kind of engineer I thought she
meant like a train engineer and she said
aeronautical engineer I said your dad is
an aeronautical engineer I said way to
go to school which he told me he went to
school a black school in the south and I
said I would imagine there's no more
than five guys his age plus or minus ten
years with a degree in aeronautical
engineering and she went back home and
asked her dad and her dad said maybe
five guards he was she was she had no
idea how rare this guy was and so I met
him I talked with him and I said what
have when you got out of school I
couldn't get a job I wrote to everywhere
which wrote the Westinghouse I wrote to
every major company and nobody would
hire me and I was gonna get on a freight
and go to Mexico because I heard they
were hiring right before I gonna get on
the freight they had no money I got a
phone call from the government and began
working for the government rest his life
engineer now in the 70s I was in college
and you in law school and I had a
roommate who was an engineer a computer
engineer and Dave the company's
recruited him like he was an NCAA and he
had another good friend too
same thing
both of them one of them ended up a long
career at Procter & Gamble and made so
much money that he dedicated a wing to
the to the computer school at Michigan
and the other one my roommate William is
still with TRW a very good career there
they were recruited like rock stars and
my my girlfriend's father could not get
a job as an engineer when he got out of
school that's the difference between and
that wasn't and and I was in in law
school in late 70s that 40 years ago
you're telling me now things aren't much
much better than even then and then they
were recruited like rock stars
knock it off do your homework graduate
from high school don't have a kid before
you're 20 years old and get married
first and you will be just fine in
America yeah and it's so interesting how
a healthy society deals with its past
and justices because I used the examples
of going to Monticello you know Thomas
Jefferson's house where you take that
tour they are very honest about his
relationship to slavery that he was
having an affair with at least one slave
and affairs is a right kind word to say
while while the same time writing the
laws that freed the slaves I went to
George Washington's house and he didn't
free his half of the slaves until he
died it was in his will but Martha still
kept the other half but they but they
acknowledge all of that and there's so
many people that just want to point at
them and say they were racists and the
country was founded by them and they
knew was a cancer and it was and that it
was going to at some point after the
point where something had to be done
they knew it Ben Franklin his last
speech was a fiery speech urging the
abolition of slavery in fact he found it
in a Society for the abolition of
slavery so the founding fathers many of
them were conflicted but many of them
were aware that this is something that
we need to deal with energy know that in
the Constitution there's a specific date
that says at this point there's there'll
be no more import a Shinto slaves and it
was 1824 and yet people want to want to
kind of sit in this and not let us
escape and then and then it leads to
identity politics on the left which then
I think is the reason that we now have a
version of identity politics on the
right and then that we're caught well
seven billion people are in the world
and I dare say that most of them would
trade places with us if they could
and most Americans many Americans
unfortunately don't don't seem to
appreciate that yeah all right so let's
talk about California a little bit in LA
in particular because as you said born
and bred in LA south-central if I'm not
mistaken right now they call it South LA
because South Central has a negative
connotation so you moved it now they
call it south or south that's very fancy
that's very fancy but we actually live
about ten minutes away from me how Oh
somebody is in LA if they refer to the
area where I grew up in South Central
for the south yeah anybody north of 50
call this house in 20 by south of 50
calls it I did not even know it was
South LA you know I knew there was a
West LA LA because South Central became
synonymous with black LA and that's
racist so therefore they stopped doing
it I think also real tours didn't like
it either they didn't like the area
being called South Central because it
meant the property values might might
not be as high yeah well we also have an
area here Baldwin Hills that's known as
the black right Beverly Hills and
actually when I was going to buy a house
when I was ended up at this house I went
to Baldwin Hillier and it's gorgeous I
didn't know I actually didn't know that
it was known as the black Beverly Hills
and obviously that wouldn't have
bothered me everything but when I went
to the house and I'm looking at the
house was actually pretty nice and the
price is pretty pretty decent relative
to whatever because there's some oil
things over there and whatever else I
remember the the realtor was like and
you know it's 90% black and 6% Hispanic
and 2% white or something and I was like
but alright yeah okay we're all we're
all humans alright but I want to talk
about LA and California in general
because I do sense that because
progressive politics have gone so
bananas here and you reference San
Francisco earlier and I was just there
and our car got broken into and they
stole my bag and you know basically 10
o'clock at night in front of a nice
restaurant and I literally saw someone
shooting up and there were there were
homeless tents and all of this stuff I
think that because progressive politics
have gone so overboard that there is a
little bit of a libertarian streak
starting to take root here I took a deep
breath in as I said I hope you're right
because the homelessness problem is
massive our budgets are terrible the
fast growing item on the budget is
funded pension liabilities from all the
generous packages we've given to
government workers those workers are
young many of them I think in California
I read there about ten thousand former
government workers that get pensions of
a hundred thousand dollars a year or
more for the rest of their lives which
are adjusted for cost of living far more
generous than any pension you get in the
private sector some of you could get one
in the first place
so that's on automatic pilot and we're
driving away businesses with all the
taxes California has been rated the
worst state in which to do business for
every single year a magazine called CEO
magazine has been in business and small
business people have also rated it as
one of the worst places in which to do
business that's why we're losing in
digitus population people born and
raised in California going to places
like Texas and Nevada
in Florida it's interesting I was in
Denver last week and the uber driver was
showing me how there's Denver's just
exploding right now just the whole area
is exploding and all the rural areas are
just becoming bigger and bigger and
bigger and the guy goes well you know we
got lower taxes here in Colorado so all
you rich California people are coming
here so we're really I mean people
really need to understand that people
eventually decide to use the foot vote
and go alright I'm sick of paying these
taxes I'm gonna go live in a mansion
where I can only live in a an apartment
a little going and you go online and see
it there's a there's a there's an online
site that shows where the money goes tax
revenues and we're and where it's going
where is it going and it's where it's
going to look to the so-called red
states states like Wyoming states like
that are fighting a blooming population
and states like Illinois and California
and Connecticut or losing indigenous
population to other states yeah because
the taxes and the regulations do you
think there's any chance some of this
could be reversed here you've been here
for a long time and longer I've only
been here for five years I'm just
lightly hopeful here's the problem with
California the demographics are not in
our favor in nineteen and it was 80 1994
I think it was Proposition 187 passed
talk about a quote harsh anti-illegal
immigration law one D one you tell me
187 for bad illegals using education
funds and not allow illegal aliens to
use any medical funds except for
emergency
so no no education no healthcare no
nothing illegal aliens it passed among
whites it passed among blacks it passed
among Hispanics assuming passing among
Asians it did not pass of course among
Hispanics at the time the Hispanic vote
in California may be twenty ten percent
now it's about 25% and it's rising and
Hispanics believe especially those from
Mexico Republicans are racist and they
only care about the rich early times did
a study and asked them questions like
that and those are the two we sponsored
that were the most frequent Republicans
are racist only care about the rich
selfish and only care about the rich and
they don't come from a libertarian point
of view a federalist point of view they
don't know from from Thomas Jefferson
from article 1 section 8 of the
Constitution which limits the federal
government to a handful of things
leaving everything else to the states
and the individuals they don't know from
that so the point is we got our work cut
out and got to work hard for us listen
we could do this forever that was a
quick frickin hour and I know you got a
hard out cuz you got it you got a job
yeah I have a radio show to do right you
got a radio show to do
alright we're gonna do the hem have your
fans follow me on Twitter yeah at Larry
oh they're at Larry older I'm a pro it's
all right there I'm on Twitter I call
the elders statement elder statement com
yeah what are you gonna bring the
mustache back every time I google image
search you and there's I'm gonna rock
the throwback you see you see my fro
picture that picture i retweeted that
picture because you ad that was it that
was like a well what happened is the
rest role said you think your wife
you've always wanted to be white you
probably always want to be right if I
said really and I put that picture that
went out today I want to a library so I
will concede all right man listen it's a
pleasure there is a place I don't want
to mention it on air but there is a new
restaurant right in between our houses
like right in between that is freaking
awesome right around here I'm taking out
say the word for dinner your girlfriend
you got it it's been a pleasure my
friend enjoys I'm sorry we have to do
this so quick we're gonna we'll do this
again
power to the people death to the fascist
Pig I can't do better that communication